President Trump is set to visit two
cities where the nation's most recent
mass shootings left 31 people dead some
people in those communities would rather
see him stay home the president's first
stop this morning is Dayton Ohio where a
gunman killed nine people early Sunday
he will then go to El Paso Texas where
22 people were murdered on Saturday the
suspect in that massacre is accused of
being a white supremacist who targeted
Hispanics Ben Tracy is at the White
House Ben what does the president plan
to do during his visits
well good morning the president wants to
meet with law enforcement first
responders and some family members of
those who were killed and of course this
is part of a president's job the
comforter in chief but because of some
of the things President Trump has said
and done not everyone is welcoming him
with open arms his rhetoric has been
painful for many in our community
Dayton mayor nan wale he says she will
tell President Trump directly that he's
been unhelpful in the wake of the mass
shooting in her city that left nine
people dead I think that people should
stand up and say they're not happy
mental illness and hatred pulls the
trigger
not the gun the president's response so
far is not going over well with many in
either community El Paso mayor D Margo
says he's receiving calls and emails
from residents against President Trump's
visit he is president United States so
in that capacity I will fulfill my
obligations as mayor of El Paso emotions
in El Paso are particularly raw
congresswoman Veronica Escobar says the
president should apologize for past
comments the words that he has used to
describe Mexicans and immigrants are
racist words that feel hate the accused
white supremacists who allegedly killed
22 people at the Walmart there said he
was responding to what he called the
Hispanic invasion of Texas the president
has often used the word invasion to
justify his border wall in immigration
policies million illegal aliens trying
to rush our borders it is an invasion
Mexico should step up and stop this
onslaught this invasion into our country
the president continues to insist he's
the least racist person ever and the
White House is pushing back
the pushback it's not the politicians
fault when someone acts out their evil
intention and some in El Paso like
Republican Blanca Gillian aronia see the
president as visiting out of respect for
the families he is the representative of
our nation and he's coming as such el
paso native and Democratic presidential
candidate better or Roarke says the
president should not come visit El Paso
today in a tweet last night mr. Trump
said that O'Rourke should respect the
victims and law enforcement and be quiet
or ork replied 22 people in my hometown
are dead after an act of terror inspired
by your racism El Paso will not be quiet
and neither will I now he and
congresswoman Escobar will attend a
community action event during the
president's visit Dana
Ben thank you in our next hour we will
speak to Dayton mayor nan Whaley you
heard from her there and Ben's piece
criticizing the president will talk with
her about that and also her governor's
new gun control laws that he has
proposed that's coming up at 8:00